abordando distintos temas de actualidad
varios dirigentes latinoamericanos se
dirigieron al mundo en la asamblea
nacional de la onu el jueves para cuba
la principal preocupación sigue siendo
el bloqueo económico de eeuu recrudecido
durante la pandemia del presidente de la
república de cuba el gobierno de eeuu no
ha cesado ni un minuto en sus ataques
contra cuba pero en este momento crucial
y desafiante para todas las naciones su
agresividad supera los límites el más
cruel y prolongado bloqueo económico
comercial y financiero la crudeza con la
que el kobe 19 ha dotado a toda américa
latina fue otra preocupación que los
líderes regionales llevaron ante la
cumbre con duras críticas al
funcionamiento de naciones unidas al
respecto la misma asamblea general que
hace muchos años despertaba tanto
optimismo se estaba acercando a la
obsolescencia lo volví a decir hace un
año en medio de una pandemia este año
estoy de nuevo acá viendo como no
entendimos ese aviso y nos estamos
dirigiendo hacia otra crisis mencionaron
también la crisis climática un problema
global que desde bolivia defienden de
vías por los países más desarrollados
que son según el presidente luís arte
los que más contaminan el planeta los
países del capitalismo central deben
asumir la deuda climática y la
compensación histórica con el resto de
los países del mundo mediante la
cooperación financiera el gobierno
boliviano también criticó el bloqueo a
cuba y apostó por la unidad de las
naciones ante las futuras crisis que
pueda enfrentar la humanidad